First, we'll identify unlabled
contents by using the screen reader.
[SOUND]
>> Checkbox checked.
>> The promotional offers
Checkbox isn't labeled.
There are two ways to associate
a label with the form element.
Either these methods will cause the
label text to become a click target for
the check box, which is also super
helpful for pointer based users.
We could wrap the input element in
a label element, or we could use the for
attribute of the label to associate
it with the ID of the input.
[NOISE]
>> Receive promotional offers checkbox
checked.
>> Once the checkbox has been
labeled correctly we can see that it
has a roll of checkbox,
its state is checked and
it has a label of receive
promotional offers.